und schon leute wir müssen welt wir
müssen will man oder sterben
[Applaus]
[Musik]
juni oder juli
denn sonne tram wirklich existiere dann
wäre er so ziemlich der schlecht ist das
jetzt aller zeiten weil er so viele
minderheiten und frauen getan hat
[Musik]
manchmal fragen wir uns ob es das
wirklich wert ist
aber die wahl von donald trump hat mir
gezeigt wie die welt aussehen wird wenn
menschen mit gewissen und religiöser
überzeugung stumm bleiben
es ist eine gefährliche welt für kinder
gefährliche unserer umwelt und ist
gefährlich für die politische ordnung
und das werden wir nicht tolerieren
[Musik]
konservative konnte ich nie meine
meinung sagen und wenn doch wird es
weiße rassisten genannt ohne jede
grundlage nur weil ich halt der gängigen
darstellung nicht einverstanden war
[Musik]
das was toni konkurs ausmacht ist der
kultur kampf den sie für es ist die
erste organisation die sich wirklich
wert hessen und saarland war noch nie so
positiv wie jetzt ich sehe dass überall
und präsident ron hat amerika gezeigt
dass es in ordnung ist ein kämpfer für
das zu sein woran man glaubt
[Musik]
wir sind auf einer tour durch das ganze
land von küste zu küste von grenze zu
grenze geladen religiöse wähler ein die
wiederwahl von donald trump zu
verhindern und das allgemeinwohl zu
ihrem obersten wahl kriterium zu machen
[Musik]
das interessante an dieser
präsidentschaftswahl ist das überall
egal wohin wir kommen jeder einem einher
zu halten ich habe noch niemanden
getroffen der gesagt hat darüber mache
ich mir keine gedanken ich würde gerne
eines tages präsident werden
[Musik]
schalding grenze gesellschaft zum
stillstand zu bringen für eine krankheit
die so ähnlich ist wie die griffe das
ein ganz gefährlicher präzedenzfall für
alle zukünftigen pandemien obwohl sie
wissen dass religiöse wähler sagen dass
donald trump unfähig ist mit irgendwas
umzugehen
insbesondere mit den auswirkungen des
corona die ruß dürfen wir keine minute
nachlassen
[Musik]
ich bin hier bei den protesten
ich gebe heute mein bestes um die demenz
frauen vor den polizisten zu schützen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die polizisten haben gerade tränengas
benutzt
[Musik]
sie haben uns gerade einfach mit sesam
sexismus oder sexismus deine er kann
dich nicht zurück in amerika sind wir
nur begrenzt durch unsere
vorstellungskraft und unseren willen zum
erfolg nicht durch unsere hautfarbe
unser geschlecht oder wenn wir leben
[Musik]
wir wollen keine waffe gehört zu unserem
team gelingt es ist mir egal hat eine
waffe sind eine waffe hat muss ag und
hier verstehen ärger aber der kern muss
gehen er muss geht gar nicht ich bin
passt und wenn sie eine waffe haben
können sie hier nicht sein
als ich im college für meine
überzeugungen für turning point eintrat
wurde meine adresse online
veröffentlicht und ich bekam viele
morddrohungen als eine junge nur ein
meter 55 große frau war es für mich
beängstigend spät abends nach hause zu
geben
einstimmig beschlossen die möglichkeit
zu nutzen die wir in den usa haben und
habe eine lizenz zum nicht greifbaren
waffentragen beantragt um mich zu
schützen und auch andere zu verteidigen
falls etwas passiert diese woche eine
eilmeldung gegeben bei präsident trump
und der first lady wurde gerade
konzentriert
ich begebe mich in swat krankenhaus ich
glaube es geht mir sehr gut und wir
werden sicherstellen dass alles gut
läuft
als ich meine diagnose hörte habe ich
erst mal für den präsidenten und die
first lady gebetet dass ich dieses virus
schnell und ohne symptome überstehen und
ich freue mich sehr weiter dabei zu sein
und so sehen wie die unterstützung für
präsident schon sechs selbst während
dieser kurve diagnose für ihn und die
first lady
[Musik]
wir sind ungefähr sechs meilen vor
washington und unsere gruppe wird
einmarschieren zusammen mit allen
anderen die wir auf diesen es ist ein
sehr aufregender tag wieder ist wir sind
heute seit neun tagen unterwegs und sind
am ende über 130 meilen gelaufen
und das ist erst der anfang denn es ist
noch ein weiter weg um auf den rassismus
in den usa aufmerksam zu machen
ich bereite mich auf ein interview von
fox business vor dem nationalen
nachrichtenkanal
[Musik]
ich bin heute in los angeles für ein
wirklich aufregendes treffen also morgen
ist der junior der sohn des präsidenten
bei uns zu gast
i'm afraid fürchte dass es infolge der
wahlen am dritten november zu einem
aufstand der bewaffneten weißen
nationalistischen terroristen
[Musik]
ich bin umgezogen um mehr rein zu sein
am hauptquartier von turning point uk in
den letzten wochen hatte ich die ehre
mit dem weißen haus zusammen zu arbeiten
ich hatte unzählige social media
kampagnen
ich werde viele video serien in den
nächsten monaten drehen ich reise in
vier bundesstaaten allein diese woche
also es ist wirklich eine verrückte zeit
aber ich freue mich so über alles was
gerade passiert
guten morgen ich überbringe ich grüße
von einer gruppe weißer geistlicher wir
sind fest entschlossen glaube hoffnung
und liebe zurück zu bringen
durch einen regierungswechsel um den
gefährlichsten präsidenten in der
geschichte unseres landes loszuwerden
das klatschen
[Musik]